teambuilding nennt sich wenn etwas
zusammen kommen soll was bisher nicht
zueinander finden konnte oder wollte das
schicksal verschafft jetzt bündnis
grünen und fdp politische tuchfühlung
echte zuneigung wird zwar anders
buchstabiert aber die parlamentarische
demokratie ist da unerbittlich die
kanzler machen worauf einigen sich fdp
und grüne jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
[Musik]
dieses ziel wurde gestern nacht nach dem
ersten treffen noch losgeschickt die
parteispitzen von fdp und grünen und sie
machen gute miene zum
koalitionspolitischen spiel und er den
selphy wird dazu auf instagram gepostet
auf der suche nach einer neuen regierung
noten hier gemeinsamkeiten und brücken
über trennendes aus und finden sogar
welche spannende zeiten
ja da wollen wir sie mal beim wort
nehmen und damit herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste hier im studio ist
ricarda lang stellvertretende
bundesvorsitzende von bündnis 90/die
grünen und am sonntag frisch in den
bundestag gewählt
glückwunsch von alexander graf
lambsdorff der bundestag schon etwas
länger angehört der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fdp bundestagsfraktion
alexander graf lambsdorff
zugeschaltet sind ulrike winkelmann
chefredakteurin der taz und johannes
pennekamp ist bei uns der chef der
redakteur bei der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung so lang haben sie
eigentlich vertrauen in die fdp
vertrauen ach ich da bloß grad gar nicht
dass ja die frage ist sondern es geht
erstmal darum dass wir einen
regierungsauftrag haben der sich ganz
klar aus dem wahlergebnis ableiten lässt
jetzt geht es darum vertrauen zu
schaffen weil ich dafür alles klar 2017
politik des durch stechens und
gegeneinander ausspielen das darf sich
nicht wiederholen man braucht jetzt eine
regierung die wir einen kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner hat schon auch eine
gemeinsame erzählung das heißt jetzt ist
halt vertrauensbildung angesagt ramsdorf
halten sie ein scheitern der gespräche
zwischen fdp und bündnisgrünen für
möglich
möglich ist alles habe ich sie das
eigentlich nicht ich sehe den
ernsthaften willen beiden partnern genau
wie es die vorsitzenden gesagt haben
diese brücken zu finden da wo es eben
ein bisschen schwieriger ist beide sind
wir jetzt schon ziemlich lange in der
opposition beide sind wir durch das
votum der wählerinnen und wähler am
sonntag ein bisschen stärker noch
geworden wir sind sozusagen in der
situation die sie ja zum titel ihrer
sendung gemacht haben dass er so ein
bisschen wir in der rolle dieser kanzler
macher parteien geht sind und da wir
aber die beiden sind die in der
vergangenheit auch in der opposition in
den wahlkämpfen sich so ein bisschen
bekannt haben oft ist es richtig dass
wir das jetzt erst mal versuchen
zusammenzubinden also ich bin da ganz
positiv und optimistisch so winkelmann
fdp und bündnisgrüne müssen ja für eine
künftige koalition ganze kröten biotope
schlucken wird das gelingen
ich fürchte es ist grauenhaft aus dem
läuten der tour beschlossen ehrlich zu
sein aber ist alle heutigen aus dem
biotop
gravierende unterschiede weiterhin gibt
also bei allem charme der die letzten
tage schon versprüht wurde zwischen
grünen fdp und bei allen ermutigungen
die es auch herr lambsdorff gerade auch
noch erwähnt hat denke ich das ist ein
ganz fundamentalen unterschied weiterhin
gibt das ist der dass die fdp sich im
großen und ganzen den besserverdienern
der gesellschaft verpflichtet fühlt und
die grünen aber ganz klar gesagt haben
wir wollen klima schützen wir wollen ihn
sozial und da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt
den großen großen graben der pkw wird
eigentlich mit der union nur noch zum
schein geredet
den eindruck kann man so ein bisschen
haben gerade wenn man auch sieht das die
fdp jetzt sogar die gespräche mit der
union vorziehen wird und ich glaube
schon am samstag mit der union sprechen
wird das kann natürlich ein mittel sein
um druck aufzubauen auf die gespräche
die dann folgen mit der spd also das
wird wirklich spannend sein zu sehen wie
ernst das gemeint wird und wie man dann
zu dritt auch reden wird bald über die
terminierung wollte ich eigentlich
später sprechen aber im heute journal
hat volker wissing gerade gesagt das
glaube ich dass der am samstag mit der
union möglicherweise nicht klappt mit
dem gibt es zwei gründe dafür wissen sie
dass ich bin gerade ganz knapp vor der
sendung erst angekommen weil wir alle
herumtelefonieren im moment ich kann es
ihnen nicht sagen ob es klappt oder
nicht das hat aber wahrscheinlich keine
politischen gründe sondern es sind auch
logistische gründe müssen alle da sein
es gibt termine die es gibt also
tatsache ist und ich glaube das ist das
entscheidende
es gibt den willen bei allen beteiligten
ernsthaft miteinander zu sprechen und
die frage die sie gerade gestellt haben
wird zum schein mit einigen gesprochen
also jedenfalls von uns aus nicht das
kann ich versichern also dann
setzt sich jetzt trotzdem noch mal nach
wir reden ja hier über vor sondierungen
zu einer koalition an den bündnisgrünen
fdp beteiligt sein sollen und beteiligt
werden möchten können wir uns in diesem
zusammenhang von der jamaika option
verabschieden
als wir haben gesagt wir reden mit allen
parteien aber natürlich ist klar dass
die spd vorne lag als wir haben einen
wahlsieger das hat ja keine
gleichwertigen verhandlungs alternativ
man auf der einen zeitung ist der
gestärkte parteien und wahlsieger haben
auf der anderen seite eine partei mit
einer riesigen wahlschlappe die gerade
auch noch sehr in einem sortierung
prozess ist wer überhaupt
verhandlungsfähig ist der ball liegt aus
meiner sicht jetzt erstmal bei einer
ampel sondierung wir haben auftrag für
eine progressive regierung bekommen ist
ampel und jamaika für die fdp noch
gleich viel wert gleichberechtigt auf
gleicher ebene gleiche ernsthaftigkeit
ja wir sind jetzt drei tage nach
schließung der wahllokale also ich würde
deswegen jetzt eine option von nicht vom
tisch nehmen wollen ich glaube das wäre
ganz falsch wir müssen schauen dass die
spd hat die wahl gewonnen hat die union
hat schwere verluste gehabt dass beides
richtig aber im ergebnis haben die
wählerinnen und wähler am sonntag die
parteien in einem korridor von zwei
prozent sozusagen in den bundestag
gewählt die grünen haben zugelegt wir
haben zugelegt also ich denke es wäre
falsch jetzt irgendwelche optionen vom
tisch zu nehmen und wie sich parteien
sortieren ist nicht meine sache das zu
kommentieren was bei der union da
passiert ich interpretiere die
entscheidung was die fraktionsführung
dort an geht erst mal als eine
befriedung der lage insofern glaube ich
dass das wirklich wichtigste ist dass
die grünen und die freien demokraten
dass dass das trennende überbrücken und
dann mit den beiden reden und schauen wo
gibt es das beste gesamtpaket für das
ist noch nicht das ist in meinen augen
ich will das hier deutlich sagen das ist
in meinen augen noch überhaupt nicht
klar ob das bei der ampel oder bei er
michael sein wird winkelmann jamaika ist
das
handy kann hat schon auf die frage
geantwortet ist das eigentlich nur noch
steht das nur noch im raum als option
aber nicht mehr als ganz gemeinde option
hier scheint es keine verhandlungsmasse
und keine reelle option mehr zu sein
also die union hat jetzt wirklich
erfolgreich nahezu jede gelegenheit auch
seit der wahl verpennt und verbaselt
sich noch ein ernsthaft wirklich als als
verhandler ins spiel zu bringen und das
dürfte den grünen der fdp ja auch klar
sein dass sie beide optionen auf
brauchen um noch scheinbar
ausweichmöglichkeiten zu haben aber es
ist glaube ich in wirklichkeit längst
nicht mehr so der penny kamen wir reden
ja in der sendung über trennendes und
gemeinsames für bündnis grüne und fdp
die sie jetzt zu sagen wie wir auch dem
untertitel desselben haben überbrücken
wollen aber eine gemeinsam gibt es eine
gemeinsamkeit für beide parteien dass
sie jetzt eigentlich fast gezwungen sind
in regierungsverantwortung zu gehen
sonst steht es um ihre zukunft
möglicherweise nicht so gut da wie das
eben schon gesagt wurde beide parteien
waren jetzt lange in der opposition und
sie haben natürlich ein massives
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
und auch ein problem relevant zu bleiben
bei ihren wählern
wenn sie jetzt nicht die chance
ergreifen in die regierung zu gehen also
es ist anders als vor vier jahren als es
letztlich darum ging wer regiert jetzt
eigentlich weiter mitunter merke dass es
jetzt vorbei jetzt geht es ja wirklich
darum das land zu verändern zu erneuern
das sind das sind erstmal nur große wo
hatte da muss erst mal jetzt was folgen
aber aber diese chance können sich
eigentlich beide parteien nicht entgehen
lassen wenn sie also glaubwürdig bleiben
wollen schon lange will man das jetzt
mal konstatiert also die fdp hat ja
möglicherweise zwei optionen sie nimmt
jamaika noch ernst die spd hätte ja auch
zwei neben der ampel noch die groko in
der hinterhand sie haben ja durch das
was jetzt auch gerade gesagt haben ja
eigentlich gar keine option erhöhtes den
verhandlungsdruck gerade auf ihre partei
ich glaube wir haben wie die anderen
parteien auch zwei optionen wir sehen
halt dass da eine jetzt der spielball
liegt ich würde gleich noch mal ganz
kurz weil es gerade so ein bisschen
beschrieben wurde als ob es fast eine
strafe wäre jetzt einen
regierungsauftrag zu bekommen ich glaube
erst mal ist es ein positives zeichen
dass wir von der bevölkerung übrigens
gerade die beiden parteien die jetzt
hier sitzen insbesondere von jungen nur
wählerin den auftrag bekommen haben die
regierung zu bilden erneuerung zu bilden
aus meiner sicht auch den auftrag der
vielleicht ein bisschen größer ist sogar
als die einzelnen ergebnisse jetzt
klimaschutz wirklich umzusetzen das erst
mal ein riesen chance gut auf diesen
aspekt gerade der jungen wähler und was
ihre beiden parteien damit zu tun haben
durch die wahlergebnisse sollen kommen
wir gleich noch lass es doch noch mal
das bild ansehen wenn wir jetzt auf
gemeinsamkeiten kommen das bild dieses
11 dass wir am anfang noch gezeigt haben
das ist also das quartett der
brückenbauer
jetzt soll am freitag weiterverhandelt
werden alexander graf lambsdorff
genügt das eigentlich jetzt am freitag
diese zweite verhandlungsrunde um schon
so viel gemeinsamkeiten zu entdecken und
zu formulieren dass man dann in einer
größeren der möglicherweise zuerst mit
der spd so ein richtiges sondierungen
führt also erstmal muss ich sagen für
das bild echt cool ich finde das ist mal
eine geht auf jeden fall immer ja er all
seine bildsprache die hier mal in der
bundesrepublikanischen politik genutzt
wird könnte es gab noch mal dass ich so
gar nicht nur ca ich möchte sie gelesen
haben über das heute auf twitter los war
deutschlandradio kultur hat ja sogar
darum gebeten hätten das silberne und
verknüpft sind im vergleich aber der
berner gc aber ja ich finde das zeigt
einfach und das sind dann bin ich bald
mit völlig mit voll einverstanden das
ist eine moderne aufbruchs
anmutung dieses bild dort also
bildsprache ich jetzt hier transportiert
und dass auch der politische anspruch
der beiden parteien wieder stehen und
der beiden parteien die heute abend hier
sitzen wir wollen einen aufbruch
schaffen und wir haben bei den erst
wählerinnen und erstwählern unglaubliche
erfolge erzielt also der eben erst allen
die wir vorne in der jungen gruppe
liegen die grünen knapp vorne also das
ist genau das was das bild
transportieren soll und was ist auch
widerspiegelt und ich glaube und nochmal
auf das zurückzukommen so pennekamp
gesagt hat ja natürlich wir sind in
gewisser weise zum erfolg verdammt aber
das ist keine strafe das ist gut und
deswegen sage ich auch es ist wichtig
dass wir ernsthaft über alle optionen
reden und dass diese beiden teams das
jetzt machen am freitag in der zweiten
runde so das ist ein teil eines längeren
prozesses schauen sie wenn wir als wir
als freie demokraten unserem parteitag
anfang dezember gelegt wo wir hoffen ein
ergebnis beraten zu können so das heißt
wir sind jetzt ende september das ist
die zeit bis anfang dezember in der das
ganze organisiert werden soll ich finde
das ist ein überschaubarer
verantwortungsvoller zeitrahmen da
wollen wir jetzt hin verhandeln und das
wird sicherlich das letzte treffen in
dem rahmen bleiben eingewickelt man das
elf soll also ein zeichen des aufbruchs
und des reformwillens seien optisch
festgehalten könnte es auch als drohung
gegen olaf scholz oder armin laschet
oder wen auch immer in der union
aufgefasst werden
es ist auf jeden fall kokett es zeigte
so vieles was
grad schien auch mit aufgezeichnet wurde
die sind die hirnrinde sind die besser
aussehen dann sind die cooleren wir sind
die die sich schon auch ganz geheim und
zu ihrer überraschung getroffen haben am
geheimnisvollen ort also es steckt ja
alles drin natürlich darin eben auch die
drohung dass man eventuell die die spd
denn in einer ampel dann ebenfalls
überraschen könnte mit eben einigungen
an ecken und enden mit denen jetzt bin
ich verweise nicht gerechnet aber es
gibt es am wochenende dann auch noch
andere sprechen werden dass er mit der
spd treffen denn sicherlich auch eine
große nachhaltigkeit beschweren wollen
sei aber immer noch bei den
gemeinsamkeiten herr pennekamp
vielleicht ist er auch schneller drüber
zu reden oder schneller abzuhaken also
wenn man jetzt mal überlegt wo gibt es
gemeinsamkeiten auch bisher schon das
ist der ganze bereich der sogenannten
bürgerrechte datenschutz migration
digitalisierung bildung fällt ihnen da
noch etwas anderes ein wo es
möglicherweise ganz schnell gehen könnte
oder wo man oder an themen an die man
gar nicht so schnell denkt inzwischen
bündnis grünen und fdp unumstritten sind
na ja ich würde das thema migration dann
noch dazu zählen ich glaube beide sind
interessiert daran ein
einwanderungsgesetz zu machen das dann
auch wirklich fachkräfte nach
deutschland holt man sich sicherlich
schnell einig und es gibt sicherlich
auch ein paar symbole symbolische dinge
sagen wir mal zum beispiel cannabis
legalisierung das ist sicherlich etwas
das dann auch bei den jüngeren wählern
gut ankommt wo man sich schnell darauf
einigt und wo man sagen kann das haben
wir aber das sind dann natürlich nicht
die kernthemen die kernthemen sind sind
klima und steuer und da stimme ich frau
winkelmann zu da da liegt man doch noch
meilenweit auseinander
ja also ich glaube einfach nochmal zu
wissen was das eigentlich ausdruck was
wir szenen das sehen wir nicht erst
jetzt mit diesem wahltag sondern
eigentlich seit mehreren jahren ist ein
bisschen das ende der ära der
volksparteien und das ist natürlich auch
das ende der ära wo eine partei gewinnt
es gibt ein wahlsieger und dann jetzt
müssen die zugeordnete parteien für eine
partei schwitzt schlips die anderen
springen und kommen dazu und ich glaube
das ist das spannende an dieser
konstellation wir haben die größte
schnittmenge mit der spd gerade bei den
themen wo wir es sehr große unterschiede
und trinke man vollkommen recht da
werden wir darauf eingehen in der
sozialpolitik in der steuerpolitik gibt
es riesige unterschiede und damit viele
schnittmengen mit der spd und trotzdem
ist glaube ich diese wechsel eines modus
wie auch so eine regierung zusammen
kommt das ist eigentlich das spannende
was da gerade passieren kann und
vielleicht auch was ein bisschen zu
einem neuen politikstil und einer neuen
form des regierens führen kann also ich
glaube wir haben ein feld noch
ausgelassen ich weiß dass es nicht im
zentrum der aufmerksamkeit steht aber
dass ganze familien recht beispielsweise
selbstbestimmte
sozialen selbstbestimmte entscheidungen
in allen lebenslagen auch am ende des
lebens abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a
lg bietet korrekte roth der werbe hier
das verbot regenauer der information das
ist ja fast nur information und wir
haben ganz viele gesellschaftspolitische
nähen zu den grünen auch weil unsere
haben unsere wähler schafften ähneln
sich in mancherlei hinsicht ja auch und
ich glaube dass es deswegen gelingen
wird werden kann sagt das ist nicht die
kernthemen aber es sind themen die
unheimlich viele menschen in diesem land
betreffen und wenn es dann gelingt
modernisierungsschub reinzukriegen wäre
mir das sehr recht wir haben natürlich
das stimmt in der finanzpolitik
unterschiedliches verständnis wird wie
vor soll der staat machen was soll der
privatsektor machen dann müssen wir
zusammen kommen wird nicht einfach aber
ich halte es auch nicht für
ausgeschlossen
jetzt kommen wir mal zu den knackpunkten
also zu den themen den kernthemen die
umstritten sind das ist die
steuerpolitik hier ist mehrfach das
schon gesagt worden sie wollen die
steuern senken für alle sie wollen die
steuern für sehr gut verdienende
gutverdienende erhöhen es gibt noch
unterschiedliche auffassungen von
schulden bleiben sie wollen es wieder
einführen sie wollen sie insofern muss
ich am noch an also wir haben bestimmt
am brüder jetzt ja ausgesetzt durch die
crawler pandemie sie wollen sich
insofern lockern als investitionen in
klimaschutz davon nicht betroffen sein
sollen mit einem sonderfonds vielleicht
wenn man sich das ich will jetzt nicht
alles aufzählen ist es ja auch die
nachrichtensendung heute wieder mehrfach
die tabelle und die verschiedenen
kategorien sind ja aufgezählt worden
wenn man sich das alles die unterschiede
zwischen ihren beiden parteien anzieht
dann wäre ein kompromiss wie immer der
einen koalitionsvertrag aussehe gleich
noch einer quadratur des kreises
naja ich muss ja erstmal sagen ich habe
vorher gesagt dass wir mit einer
verantwortung darin als wenn die
wählerinnen haben ihr votum abgegeben
ich hätte mir auch andere
konstellationen vorstellen können jetzt
nicht möglich sind aber erst mal gibt's
ja sozusagen den wählerinnen wären hätte
ich mir auch vorstellen dann müssen ja
irgendwas über dürfen
ich muss einfach sagen als parteien naja
das ist nicht machbar dass wir zusammen
finden und am ende steht wieder eine
große koalition und ich glaube daran hat
wirklich gar niemand in diesem land
irgendein interesse das muss natürlich
versuchen zusammenzufinden und ich
glaube es ist wichtig dass man
leitlinien definiert wir haben die für
uns zum beispiel wenn die finanzpolitik
anschauen ist klar es müssen mehr
öffentliche investitionen möglich werden
die brauchen wir für den klimaschutz die
brauchen aber auch im bereich der
bildung wenn wir jetzt nicht investieren
und dadurch auch mehr privates geld auch
heben dann bedeutet es einmal dass wir
chancen außen vor lassen die wir bei der
jetzigen zinssätzen gerade haben und
zweitens dass wir uns in zukünftigen
generationen schuldig machen haben die
ziellinie und dann müssen wir gucken wie
findet man im instrument zusammen keinen
raum für steuererleichterungen die sich
alexander graf lambsdorff wünscht
uns ist es so erst mal die
schuldenbremse das ganz klar zu sagen
die steht im grundgesetz und ich glaube
gerade die korona lage hat ja gezeigt in
ausnahmesituationen kann man von ihr
abweichen sie hat übrigens eine
konjunktur komponente das heißt in der
schwachen konjunktur kann man auch mehr
kredite aufnehmen aber was mir wichtig
ist und ich glaube das ist das
grundprinzip dass mir wirklich wichtig
ist nachhaltigkeit ist ein ökologischer
begriff ist aber auch ein ökonomischer
begriff wenn wir zu viele schulden
aufnehmen wenn wir zurückgehen in das
alte system der exzessiven
staatsverschuldung dann binden wir
kommende generationen durch den
schuldendienst in den bundeshaushalt und
entwerten in der zukunft die
demokratische wahl weil das
haushaltsrecht des parlaments so
eingeschränkt ist dass man gar nicht
mehr den spielraum hat um politische
wirklich prioritäten zu setzen und
deswegen noch mal wir haben viele erst
wählerinnen und erst werde ich vermute
mal bei ihnen die ökologischen und
ökonomischen weil ganz grob gesagt aber
diese nachhaltigkeit idee
gestaltungsspielräume auch in der
zukunft zu erhalten die leitet uns in
unserer haushaltspolitik und deswegen
das ist nicht eine ein rigides
festhalten an einem dogma aus
irgendwelcher verstocktheit sondern ist
es wirklich ein profundes demokratie
politisches denken was dahinter steckt
aber damals mir wenn ich ganz so sagen
darf dann ist er darüber sprechen was
wir für einen schulden begriff haben
also verstehen wir schulden nur als die
zahlen die wir nach auf dem konto haben
oder verstehen wir schulden auch als die
frage von in welchen schulen können
zukünftige generationen lernen gibt es
noch ein gesundheitssystem in dem er
mitarbeiten will und natürlich
insbesondere haben wir einen planeten
auf dem es sich noch gut leben lässt
auch das ist eine form von schulden und
das stärkste fahrrad beharren auf der
schuldenbremse führt dazu dass wir in
diesem bereich stärkere schulden fast
schulden für die zukünftigen generation
schaffen auch das ist eine frage von
generationengerechtigkeit und muss
aussagen investitionen schaffen vermögen
machen weil sie haben jetzt geschildert
wofür sie stehen jetzt haben unsere
journalistischen kolleginnen und
kollegen und die winkelmann und johannes
pennekamp aufmerksam zugehört frau
winkelmann was sie da jetzt gehört haben
wie steinig ist in der steuer und
finanzpolitik der weg zur einigung erst
mal zwischen den grünen und der fdp
bevor es dann mit dem großen parkplatz
eingemachte geht
also die fdp hat sich darauf festgelegt
die schuldenbremse erhalten zu wollen
und auch offiziell nicht unterschätzen
zu wollen und das ging ja auch ohnehin
mit der zweidrittelmehrheit gehe ja
nicht bekommen werden aller voraussicht
nach worauf aber sowohl grüne als auch
fdp sicher hinten und herren aus
einigen konnten war dass man ja die
schuldenbremse vielleicht einfach mal
beiseite
stehen lässt und stattdessen so genannte
sonderfall so vorgang das heißt es man
auch die im wesentlichen auch
steuerfinanziert sind als vergällt
besteht aber aus denen man seine
investitionen tätigen und nach allem was
ich lese und höre es darauf hinauslaufen
dass tatsächlich sich darauf einigen
könnten nach dem motto schuld brennt
schon gut lassen wir das mal so stehen
lassen wir nicht weiter an aber aus
großen sondern
[Musik]
im moment ein bild und ton problem zu
unrecht winkel magnetisierung und
probieren sie es nochmal frau winkelmann
jetzt glaub ich wieder etwas besser
geworden aber es tut mir leid ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich unterbrochen wurde gut
sie haben das zu den schulden bleiben so
gesagt ich gebe mal das wort weiter an
johannes pennekamp jetzt wird ja
schuldenbremse steuerpolitik senkung
erhöhung wie geht man mit dem soli um
gibt es einen höheren spitzensteuersatz
wird ja verhandelt jetzt zwischen oder
sondiert zwischen bündnis grünen und fdp
aber möglicherweise machen ja die beiden
dann die rechnung ohne den wirt denn da
gibt es ja zum beispiel die spd die
gerade in diesem bereich steuer und
finanzpolitik ganz und gar eigenen
vorstellungen hat und immerhin der
größte der koalitionspartner der
künftigen ist geht das ganze dann von
vorne los und was ist dann eine einigung
zwischen fdp und grünen wert
ja also ich denke zwischen grünen und
spd ist die schnittmenge da schon
relativ groß das heißt für mich dass
eine einigung zwischen fdp und grünen
dann schon schon die richtung zumindest
anzeigt ich glaube die schuldenbremse
müssen wir gar nicht groß reden die
steht im grundgesetz die wird nicht
gegen den willen der union
verschwinden das heißt wie frau
winkelmann das gesagt hat die
wahrscheinliche lösung ist dass man eben
mit mit staatlichen sonderfonds agiert
die dann zweckgebunden für für
investitionen für klima ausgaben zum
beispiel genutzt werden also dass das
scheint mir eine realistische option
und ansonsten in steuerfragen wird es
sicherlich auch ein kompromiss gehen der
in die richtung geht das der der soli
wegfällt den ja sowieso das
bundesverfassungsgericht abräumen wird
und man dann sich aber vielleicht darauf
einig den spitzensteuersatz etwas zu
erhöhen vielleicht etwas später
einsetzen zu lassen als heute da käme
dann jeder so ein bisschen auf seine
kosten das heißt ja ein kompromiss
möglich aber es wird so ein bisschen so
ein so ein laues lüftchen am ende
glauben gut dann nehme ich das nochmal
auf und wiederhole noch mal eine frage
und wir probieren es nochmal mit ulrike
winkelmann was sich wenn sich da als
eine einigung abzeichnet zwischen eines
grünen fdp
könnte dass sie wie gesagt ja insofern
vergeblich gewesen seien als die spd
sagt nehmen mit uns machen wir das so
nicht dann wird alles wieder aufgetrennt
was bedeutet dass auch für die
koalitionsverhandlungen dass man jetzt
sozusagen auf ganz unterschiedlicher
ebene verhandelt erst mal die beiden
kleineren und dann im dreier konsortium
wird dass die verhandlungen erschweren
natürlich natürlich ist es schwer sich
mit drei leuten zu einigen als oder mit
drei parteien als mit 2 1 aber in die
sache mit dem sonderform zum beispiel
scheint mir doch weit verbreitet zu sein
und auch weitgehend stimmung auch in spd
reihen zu finden das ist einfach jetzt
schon letzten anderthalb vielleicht
sollten zwei jahre ja in allen parteien
auch diskutiert worden ein anderer punkt
ist dann eben welche dimension
investition nicht aus unsere form
finanzieren und ob ich gleichwohl dann
noch steuersenkungen versprechen kann
wie das ja die fdp tue und ich
spätestens da werden sich grüne und spd
zusammenfinden und zwar gegen die und
dann wird es vielleicht zu kleineren
verschiebungen kommen kann eine kam
gerade andeutete man könnte zum beispiel
die abschaffung des soli halten eine
reform der einkommenssteuer verbergen
oder einbauen aber dann ist natürlich
dann auch so schwierig das heißt aber
die fdp anhänger und wähler die die ihre
partei gewählt haben die werden ja sagen
kommt mir bloß nicht ohne steuersenkung
nach hause wie gehen sie dann mit dieser
situation um wenn sie da keinen
widerhall findet also ein bisschen
erstaunt für die schuld dass wir alles
schon wissen und sozusagen was schon
klar sein soll also zu den sonderfonds
da sind wir eher skeptisch was sowas
angeht einfach aus dem grund dass das
natürlich neben haushalte sind es gibt
instrumente mit förderbanken über die
man reden kann aber das ist ein anderes
ist eine andere hebel dem er da machen
zur vorstellung der spd
also es gibt durchaus möglichkeiten was
zu tun aber solche neben fonds sind
immer etwas hinter der vergangenheit
haben wir das kritisch gesehen dass der
eine punkte zweiter punkt ich sage ihnen
jetzt was das wird sich überraschen die
fdp möchte das steueraufkommen insgesamt
erhöhen in der frist also auf der
zeitschiene und wir glauben dass wir das
dadurch schaffen dass wir eben entlasten
investitionsanreize schaffen denn wenn
frau lang von investitionen spricht im
öffentlichen sektor dann ist das völlig
okay und ich stimme ihnen zu wir müssen
natürlich auch öffentliche investitionen
machen ist gar keine frage na ob das
schulgebäude sind breitbandausbau klima
und so weiter aber jeder euro den wir es
öffentlich investieren dem stehen acht
bis neun euro gegenüber die ein privater
liquidität da sind und investiert werden
sollen und wir haben schon vor corinna
eine situation gehabt dass der wert der
abschreibungen in deutschland höhere als
die werte neuinvestitionen wir haben
also eine schleichende
deindustrialisierung gehabt und das
wollen wir umdrehen weil eines ist
vollkommen klar alle sozialen ziele alle
ökologischen ziele alle technologischen
ziel der öffentlichen hand erreichen wir
nur auf der grundlage einer starken
wirtschaft die uns dieses
steueraufkommen generiert und deswegen
ist eine entlastung in der kurzen frist
der weg hin zu mehr investitionen zb
eine neue abschreibungsregelungen hin zu
einem höheren steueraufkommen und mehr
handlungsfähigkeit des staates aber ich
hab einen kamm schert sich da gerade
dank ich wollte kurz kurz noch einfügen
wir können dieses thema eigentlich nicht
nicht diskutieren ohne mal kurz darüber
nachzudenken wie es im haushalt
eigentlich aussieht man muss ich
vielleicht noch einmal kurz bewusst
machen im kommenden jahr fehlen im
haushalt 100 milliarden euro es werden
100 milliarden euro strukturell mehr
ausgegeben als wir an einnahmen haben
das geht noch weil die weil die
schuldenbremse ausgesetzt ist schon im
jahr danach muss das wieder reduziert
werden auf ungefähr zehn milliarden das
heißt es muss massiv gespart werden und
sparen kann man ja natürlich auch in dem
man ausgaben kürzt und gerade da sehe
ich eigentlich auch die fdp in der
pflicht da jetzt ein paar vorschläge zu
liefern und erstaunt mich ein bisschen
dass wir da noch so wenig darüber
gesprochen haben viel über über
steuerreform steuererhöhungen
steuersenkungen aber
es geht ja worauf sich einigen können
das geht die man dann vielleicht das
ganz kurz abschließen können das wäre
vielleicht überraschend hier ich glaube
es ist niemand überraschen dass die fdp
auf den titel down effekt setzt also die
vorstellung alles lassen aber der
funktioniert ja nicht anders sieht man
las und bekam erst einmal sich anschauen
was sogar den us präsident joe biden
sagt also die
so erklären dass langsam nach durch
steuerentlastungen investitionen
anreizen und dann gehen die steuern
und dann programme man muss schon einmal
sagen die vorstellung bei den zahlen die
hier gerade genannt worden bei der
schwierigen haushaltslage die wir zahlen
wir bleiben bei der schuldenbremse und
gleichzeitig verringert
steuererleichterung insbesondere für die
menschen schon unglaublich viel haben
also entlasten verein besserverdienende
das ist sehr finanzpolitisches
irgendwie einen die wahl kam dann hier
gerade wieder passiert er ist jetzt ja
einigen das war ja die frage wie
reinigungs pro jahr also der punkt ist
folgender es geht hier nicht um einen
sozusagen renault mix
satellite trickle down effekt um
sozusagen über die ganzen horror
gespenster der sozusagen linkeren
ökonomik hier zu mobilisieren worum es
tatsächlich geht ist dass wir einen
unternehmens steuersystem braune
körperschaftsteuer einkommenssteuer das
uns wettbewerbsfähig macht wir haben wir
sehen es in frankreich die wachsen
schneller aus der krise heraus als wir
wir sehen uns in italien die wachsen
doppelt so schnell aus der krise heraus
wie wir wir haben ihre steuerreform noch
die amerikaner haben es gemacht die so
wörtlich in esens gemacht also es gibt
eine ganze reihe von ländern die diesen
weg gegangen sind und der punkt ist der
wir müssen als standort auch für
investitionen attraktiv sein das heißt
wir müssen ja auch leute anziehen die
hier investieren wir freuen uns alle
über idol maske und die firma hier in
brandenburg aber so was brauchen wir
öfter also wir brauchen mehr firmen die
hier investieren und jobs schaffen eine
starke wirtschaft ist die wirklich
absolut unabdingbare grundlage dafür
dass wir diese ziele erreichen und noch
mal das ist nicht spickel daun das ist
ein leistungsfähiger staat der auf der
grundlage einer leistungsfähigen
wirtschaft seine ziele erreichen kann
und das ist mir ganz wichtig so
pennekamp ein eine ausgabe die ich ihn
sofort sagen kann die wir streichen
würden sind subventionen für
elektroautos es gibt überhaupt keinen
grund elektroautos zu subventionieren
diejenigen die sich die leisten können
der sind und die sind inzwischen den
massenmarkt angekommen können die auch
selber bezahlen also 2000 euro über den
lebenszyklus eines e autos sind eine
überflüssige trotzdem einen break machen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
arbeitsgruppe die sich bei
koalitionsverhandlungen mit
steuerpolitik
beschäftigt vor allen dingen von leuten
wahrscheinlich oder die leute einziehen
werden die relativ wenig schlaf brauchen
werden und lange verhandeln können das
ist in den anderen gruppen aus
und entwickelte man wie ist gefroren
schon mal angeklungen die bei den
erstwählern haben 23 prozent das hat
viele überrascht
die fdp und 22 die grünen davon weniger
überrascht gewählt also 23 prozent fdp
gerade diese wähler sagen es geht uns
auch ums klima aber genauso wichtig sind
digitalisierung und innovation wenn man
jetzt diese punkte mal zusammen zieht
was die jungen wähler 23 und 22 prozent
das sind fast die hälfte aller
jungwähler die airline fdp und
bündnisgrüne wählen ist das der bereich
der sich auch ergänzt der eng
zusammenhängt wo sich fdp und
bündnisgrüne vielleicht sogar einigen
können das heißt dass die jungwähler die
erstwähler die beiden parteien erst
drauf gebracht haben wo eigentlich der
knackpunkt liegt und wo auch eine
einigung möglich ist so eine koalition
ja ich glaube dass hier eine generation
sich darauf einigen können dass sie in
der panini schlicht vernachlässigt wurde
also nach den jungen leuten wurde
einfach zuletzt gefragt nicht nur die
schülerinnen und schüler sondern auch
die studierenden sind schlicht abgehängt
worden und nach den hat niemand geschaut
und sind vollkommen zu recht sauer auf
alles was großkoalitionär riecht oder
das was von spd und cdu und csu regiert
worden ist und hier finden sie
sicherlich die grünen und die fdp
wählerinnen und wähler in den jüngeren
jahrgängen wobei man nicht vergessen
darf dass die bildungsministerin
minister übrigen bundesländern ja auch
von unter einem grünen gestellt werden
und fdp aber ich glaube das ist sehr
viel auch damit zu tun hat wie die fdp
sich geriert hat die letzten jahre dass
er sehr viele junge leute was sie darauf
anspringen christian endter es ja quasi
zum influenza in gewisser weise seiner
partei auch montiert durch die enormen
social media präsenz und so weiter und
sofort hat er da einfach auch ästhetisch
geschmacklich nerv getroffen bei den 18
bis 24 jährigen während die grünen er
doch die jungen leute anziehen die
schlicht das klima im mittelpunkt
stellen und sich sagen wir sind die
generation die von den jetzt bisher
regiert haben den generationen auch ja
im grunde ebenfalls ist die klimapolitik
hinten angestellt worden sind wir müssen
das ausbaden was die großkoalitionäre
verbockt haben wir sind schon zwei auch
unterschiedliche sorgen von
betroffenheit das passt sozusagen den
rationell zu sein nicht unbedingt in der
sache da wirklich ganz kurz zu sagen hat
schon recht das ästhetisch
geschmackliche spielt sicher eine rolle
aber das wäre alleine nicht ausreichen
ich glaube das muss man das will ich
hier nochmal sagen denn das ist der
inter steht ein lebensgefühl das ist
dieses lebensgefühl toleranz
weltoffenheit aber eben auch
leistungsbereitschaft aufstiegswillen
rationalität optimismus das ist ein
ganzes lebensgefühl und das ist bei
jungen leuten eines das man dass man das
kann sie mit händen greifen wenn sie auf
fdp veranstaltungen gehen wenn der
christian lindner auf den marktplätzen
der republik spricht da stehen die leute
schlange um selfish zu machen 100e 140
hunderte junger leute die diese die sich
von diesem lebensgefühl angesprochen
fühlen es wird dann umgesetzt das stimmt
in der ästhetik aber es ist nicht nur
die ästhetik dahinter steht mehr gut
dahinter könnte er auch jetzt zum thema
klima noch andere stecken in bezug auf
die grünen frei des for future zum
beispiel junge menschen die sagen das
ist unsere zukunft und den älteren
vorwerfen ihr ruiniert die gerade durch
euer konsumverhalten aber haben die
grünen vielleicht übersehen dass eben
nicht alle jugendlichen das klima so
absolut setzen sondern ich habe ja
gerade die beiden anderen punkte genannt
digitalisierung und innovation für sie
genauso wichtig ist ich glaube erstmals
hat das ergebnis der fdp war
überraschend ex agrar für mich auch
überraschend trotzdem halte ich gar
nichts davon was jetzt auch teil so ein
bisschen sozialen medien stattgefunden
hat dass man sich da fast über die
wählerin lustig machten diese generation
das so ein bisschen fertig macht dafür
erst mal muss man das ernst nehmen dass
ich da ganz viele junge wählerinnen so
entschieden haben ich glaube wir müssen
ein bisschen davon wegkommen gerne
generation zu homogenisieren also die
junge generation bild lassen dass
offensichtlich am wählerin von fdp und
grünen erst mal sehr unterschiedliche
politische ansichten und
unterschiedliche politische interessen
und das gilt offensichtlich auch von
jungen generation
was man aber tatsächlich sehen kann ich
glaube einmal dieses vergessen werden in
der pandemie was frau winkelmann
angesprochen hatte und das vergessen von
zukunftsthemen also dass dieses gefühl
glaube ich in einer jüngeren generation
von klimaschutz digitalisierung das sind
ja nicht ganz zufälligerweise genau die
themen die die große koalition liegen
lassen hat in den letzten jahren und da
geht jetzt eine riesige
erwartungshaltung eine neue regierung
und da muss mehr aussagen beim
klimaschutz wird sich jede regierung
egal wie sie zusammensetzen wird andere
ende an der realität als am pariser
klimaabkommen und unseren
klimaschutzzielen messen lassen wir
wollen uns an da auch an der realität
orientieren zunächst mal herr pennekamp
was das klima angeht da gibt es ja
durchaus auch unterschiede zwischen fdp
und bündnisgrünen mal kurz
zusammengefasst die fdp sagt soll
wesentlichen der markt mit entscheiden
technologieoffenheit das muss gefördert
werden um den klimawandel
also besser gesagt den klimaschutz zu
forcieren die grünen sagen da muss es
klare gesetzliche vorgaben geben also
auch staatlicher einfluss wie kann das
zusammengehen denn dass sie da auch ganz
unterschiedliche jahr
grundsätzliche prinzipielle politische
herangehensweisen
dann haben sie jetzt auch bei uns der
staat ganz sicher ganz sicher das sind
große probleme da gibt es jetzt auch
keine pauschale antwort wie das
zusammengehen wird also da müssen sich
beide seiten bewegen und ja die fdp
kommt über den marktmechanismus sagt wir
müssen ganz viel über den
emissionshandel und den co2 preis regeln
was ökonomisch total sinnvoll ist das
ist der der günstigste weg sozusagen zu
mehr klimaschutz man muss dann aber wenn
es hart auf hart kommt auch dazu stehen
und nicht nicht zum beispiel wie herr
lindner wenn der benzinpreis steigt dann
direkt sagen wir brauchen eine
benzinpreis bremse also dass das passt
nicht zusammen das muss man dann
konsequent machen und ja die grünen die
grünen haben glaube ich gelernt dass man
mit vielen vielen aussagen da auch nicht
nicht nur auf wohlwollen stößt also als
frau berbalk im wahlkampf dann wieder
sagte jedes verbot ist ein
innovationstreiber hat das glaube ich
eher im wahlkampf auch nicht gerade
geholfen und und diese denkweise in der
klimapolitik führt auch nicht weiter das
heißt das wird sehr interessant wie die
dann miteinander klarkommen die frage
ist ja wie soll es jetzt weitergehen mit
dem klima man kann ja sagen man
überlässt das innovationsentwicklung das
kann aber sein dass es dann auf der
zeitschiene durchaus länger dauert da
werden dann die grünen unruhig die sagen
nee das muss schneller gehen denn wir
haben ja klare zeitliche vorgaben was
die klimaneutralität angeht das pariser
klimaabkommen da muss man auch staatlich
da muss man politisch nachhelfen also
was wir gesagt haben ist und dass nicht
viel das noch mal so zu sagen weil sie
gerade so gefragt die fdp sagt der markt
soll alles regeln nein der staat setzt
den rahmen also das ist ja sozusagen
klassische ordoliberale ansatz der staat
setzt einem rahmen in dem dann
marktmechanismen würden aber der rahmen
das ist das klima budget das ist die
zahl an tonnen die wir noch ausstoßen
können und jede einzelne tonne kriegt
ihren preis und das ist ein pen kameras
richtig gesagt ist der günstigste
effektivste weg die bei den gering den
geringsten vermeidungskosten tatsächlich
die meisten einsparungen zu erreichen
ich will ergänzen plus klima
außenpolitik wir brauchen auch nach
außen eine stärkere einbindung der
anderen aber ein punkt ist mir auch
wichtig und das ist glaube ich mich
entscheiden kann sie haben gerade gesagt
wenn man das so macht dann darf man auf
gar keinen fall an anderen
stellschrauben drehen nein ich kann nur
daran erinnern was in frankreich
passiert ist als emanuel makro aus guten
willen die pariser klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen
eine verkehrspolitische maßnahmen
gemacht hat mit dem tempolimit auf den
landstraßen und mit der erhöhung der
preise für sprit das hat die geld festen
proteste im ganzen land ausgelöst da ist
die formulierung von ihnen herr keller
oder sie haben gesagt erkennen kann dass
nicht jede äußerung jede maßnahme sofort
auf wohlwollen stößt ist ja noch milde
also wir müssen so machen wir müssen
diesen umbau der gesellschaft richtung
klimaneutralität so machen dass alle
mitgehen können deswegen haben die
grünen ein klima geld wir haben eine
klima dividende das sind dinge woher
soll ich aber
laufen dann aber ein durchaus durchaus
parallel in der denke der die richtung
ist klar wir reden über die instrumente
und wir reden über feintuning bei der
dämpfung von bestimmten wirkungen und
dass man eine gewalttätige und
aggressive gelb westen bewegung wollen
sie in deutschland auch nicht
provozieren man muss ja der ehrlichkeit
halber sagen dass die gelb westen wie
mich einfach nur daher kam dass
klimaschutzmaßnahmen gemacht wurden
sondern dass man gleich ist und über
eine lange zeit die soziale
ungleichheiten diesem land massiv
zugenommen hat und das ist natürlich
eine explosive mischung wenn man eine
große soziale ungleichheit hat und dann
noch das gefühl hat okay jetzt werden
wir ein gläschen schnaps
lage in den bulli müssen wir ganz klar
sagen klimaschutz wenn er gut gemacht
hat dann verschärft dass soziale
ungleichheit nicht aber er kann sie auch
nicht selbst aufheben dafür brauchst du
soziale politik dafür braucht eine gute
arbeitsmarktpolitik deshalb wollen wir
ja und ich glaube dass wir wieder mit
der spd sehr gemeinsam den mindestlohn
endlich auf 12 euro anheben ich glaube
trotzdem dass bild was hier teilweise ja
nicht nur hier immer wieder gezeichnet
wird die grünen wollen nur staat die fdp
will nur markt das ist ja ein verzerrtes
bild sie haben den ordnungsrechtlichen
punkt in ihrem programm und wir sagen
ganz klar die märkte zukunft werden
rat sein was eigentlich der springende
punkt ist und das wird glaube ich auch
der schwierige verhandlungspunkt sein
ist welche rolle nimmt der preis ein
weil das was hier als konzept haben ist
ja am ende ein konzept wo der preis
eigentlich sozusagen das entscheidende
kriterium und der entscheidende maßstab
wird das ist meine sich ziemlich schnell
und sozial selbst wenn man wie es ja
sagen energie geld macht oder wie sie es
sagen eine klima dividende kann das
einst so stark steigenden co2 preis kaum
aufhalten und es wird natürlich dazu
werden dann gerade menschen ländlichen
raum die könnte wirklich autofahren kaum
noch leisten aber es gibt noch keine
alternative es gibt noch keine satz es
gibt dort kein bus keine bahn dafür
brauchen wir investitionen dafür
brauchen wir ordnungsrecht und dafür
brauchen wir ein konkretes
zwischen klima und sozialpolitik jetzt
kommen auf unseren untertitel zurück
worauf können sie sich einigen glauben
sie dass da eine einigung möglich ist
wir müssen jetzt nicht jedes detail
durch diskutieren von den arbeitsgruppen
ja nicht vorgreifen also insofern dafür
auch keine koalitionsverhandlung im
fernsehstudio das würden wir alles
wahnsinnig sympathisch aber soweit
okay das ist ja das alles auch erkennen
kann man am anfang sagte was auch sie
gefragt haben wir können ihnen heute
abend hier nicht sagen weder frau lang
noch ich wo wir uns da genau treffen
werden was wir ihnen versichern können
dass wir den zuschauern und zuschauen
aber versichern können ist es beide
parteien wirklich ernsthaft an diesen
prozess rangehen das auszuhandeln das
ist das mandat dass uns die menschen in
diesem land gegeben haben und natürlich
wird das schlaflose nächte bedeuten und
ewig lange sitzungen und ganz klar aber
wir werden am ende da bin ich wirklich
zuversichtlich ist schaffen mit einem
konzept rauszukommen das dann auch mehr
sein wird als nur so ein sohn lauer
profis erkennen kann hat also eine
befürchtung da eben geäußert ich gebe
dir nochmal zurück zu dem foto der ist
der wille da diese modernisierung zu
schaffen wir haben die erst wähler
angesprochen klimaschutz digitalisierung
grüne fdp es passt eigentlich wirklich
gut zusammen wir müssen das jetzt
hinkriegen da bin ich wirklich fest von
überzeugt gut das haben sie am anfang
auf die frage gegangen ist die gespräche
dürfen nicht scheitern und ricke
winkelmann wenn wir mal auf die
koalitionspolitische
koalitionspolitische ebene zurückkehren
wer hat denn jetzt das heft des handelns
in der hand das ist ja ein
ungewöhnlicher vorgang den wir diese
woche erleben zwei kleine da wollen sich
erst mal einigen der größere oder beide
größere stehen wie bestellt und nicht
abgeholt am spielfeldrand und gucken zu
bis man sich geeinigt hat und wissen man
dann am wochenende möglicherweise zu
einem termin gebetet gebeten wird wie
sieht das aus oder wie muss man sich das
jetzt vorstellen werden auch in den
koalitionsverhandlungen fdp und grüne
wir gehen davon aus mit der spd auch da
die dominierend faktoren seien oder wie
sich die spd da noch ins spiel bringen
die spd hatte ich bisher
nicht so blöd angestellt dass man
unterstellen müsste das jetzt irgendwie
unterschied in den spielen und natürlich
haben grüne und spd auch schon längere
zeit nach gemeinsamkeiten sicherlich
besucht und haben sich überlegt wie sie
die seine speziellen umverteilungs
vorstellungen der fdp ein bitten können
und einbinden können und ich bin recht
sicher dass grüne und fdp natürlich
erstmal jetzt gut beraten waren sich als
erstes zu treffen dass dann aber dass
das eigentliche spiel lauten wird das
grüne und spd zusammen überlegen können
müssen die weiße der fdp entgegenkommen
und die fdp hat eben die drohung immer
noch diese zocken kann damit dass sie im
zweifel alles platzen lässt und
positionieren marschiert das ist ja
nicht aus der welt obwohl ich mir gesagt
glaube das ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
ist weil die union sich auch in so
vieler anderer hinsicht in den letzten
tagen und wochen unmöglich gemacht hat
was glauben sie wie die
koalitionsverhandlungen verlaufen werden
mit dem unterschied zu den vorjahren wo
es einen mächtigen player gab und der
konnte sich also gar manchmal die
koalitionspartner aussuchen ja ganz
schwierig also ich denke im moment
entsteht ja manchmal so ein bisschen das
bild als als würden spd tschuldigung fdp
und grüne gemeinsame sache machen und
könnten sich den kanzler hinterher
aussuchen ich glaube so wird es nicht
kommen und die kleineren parteien müssen
auch ein bisschen aufpassen dass sie ihr
bleibt nicht über überreizen und damit
auf die nase fallen also dieses dieses
elfi und so weiter das demonstriert eine
einigkeit dass das kann auch als
provokation anderswo aufgefasst werden
also ich wage keine prognose und
schließe die groko am ende nicht ganz
aus gut das blatt nicht überreizen ist
ein stichwort rolf mützenich der heute
frisch gewählte fraktionsvorsitzende der
spd hat gestern gesagt bei den kleinen
parteien damit hat er ihre beiden
parteien gemeint muss klar sein dass das
schauspiel von vor vier jahren auf dem
balkon hier bei der parlamentarischen
gesellschaft bei den jamaika
sondierungen der aufgabe nicht gerecht
wird vor dem anstieg jetzt kann man
sagen das was man damals der gesehen hat
aber anja ihre beiden parteien auch
beteiligt dass man hier sagen manchmal
ein bisschen albern aus aber die art wie
rolf mützenich das jetzt formuliert hat
das vom zungenschlag ging so ein
bisschen wie eine gouvernante die ihren
schutzbefohlenen sagt wo es langgeht wie
ist das ein hinweis darauf ist
möglicherweise in den
koalitionsverhandlungen zugleich geht
nicht
generell haben sie nicht gut der ist aus
köln ich bin aus bonn er hat ja recht da
sind zum teil bilder entstanden die
nicht so glücklich waren und ich glaube
es sind sich alle einig dass man diesmal
nicht sozusagen wieder irgendwo
herkommen kleinen parteien ich meine sie
zusammen so stark
dass ein zeichen auf seinen anspruch
verlieren muss und ich glaube worauf
sich wahrscheinlich tatsächlich alle
einigen können ist es sollte kein
sondierung geben die bis 2017 laufen wo
dauernd durch gestochen wird wo es wenig
vertraulichkeit gibt wo jedes bild über
interpretiert wird ich glaube das wird
wichtig sein ernsthafte sondierungen zu
haben vertrauliche sondierungen zu haben
und welche die nicht das ziel haben
nachher eine komplementär koalition ihr
kriegt ein bisschen was da ihr kriegt
ein bisschen was da sondern der technik
gemeinsam erzählung und da bin ich
tatsächlich bei herr mützenich es
braucht eine regierung dies jahren
herausforderung orientiert also der
klimakrise herr zu werden die soziale
ungleichheit zu verringern und endlich
eine politik auf der höhe von einer
modernen einwanderungsgesellschaft zu
machen und wenn er das auch so sieht
dass man sich an ihm orientieren sollte
ist es auch super und winkelmann wenn er
es doch nicht so klappt wie man sich
jetzt vorstellt mit der ampel und
jamaika doch wieder ein spiel kennt wäre
eine option für die bündnisgrünen und
die fdp mit der union vielleicht doch
ernst dazu verhandeln aber ohne armin
laschet
das wäre sicherlich eine option die dann
benannt würde aber die union ist im
augenblick nicht im stande zu sagen wie
sie mit armin laschet weiter umgehen
will und wie wieder weiter verhandelt
und gehandelt werden soll daher reicht
meine fantasie aktuell nicht wie das
hinaussehen per pennekamp union mit oder
ohne laschet wenn sie noch mal ein spiel
käme
ja also ich sehe da ein großes
legitimationsproblem wenn man da jetzt
einen anderen spitzenkandidaten als
armin laschet hinstellt also dass das
sehe ich im moment nicht wir hatten ja
kannst rielle wo ein kanzlerkandidat
aufgetreten das danach einen anderen
kanzler zu wählen das kann ich mir kaum
vorstellen und sie beide
frau lang und ramsdorf würde ich gerne
eine letzte frage stellen da kann man
mit einem einzigen wort antworten
gestatten sie mir oder entschuldigen sie
die frage wer wird der nächste
finanzminister sein robert habeck oder
christian lindner
ja also ich würde sagen christian
lindner
das hat auch gute gründe wir haben einen
wahlkampf gemacht indem es insbesondere
eine starke wirtschaft soliden haushalt
steuerreform geht und wenn wir diese
ziele dann in die tat umsetzen wollen
ist es richtig dass unser
spitzenkandidat das ministerium anstrebt
außerdem herausholen als hinterhältig
die fdp in die ampel locken ich würde
sagen all das was ich gerade eben über
die sondierung gesagt hat bedeutet eben
auch dass man keine personaldebatten im
fernsehen wir klären jetzt erstmal die
inhalte die personaldebatten kommen
danach das war eine erwartbare antwort
ich bedanke mich dass sie hier waren
drei kater lang alexander graf
lambsdorff und ricke winkelmann und
johannes pennekamp liebe zuschauer
morgen in der phoenix runde auf dem weg
ins kanzleramt hat scholz die fdp spd im
griff
jetzt folgt für nichts mehr tag mit
konstanzer bratzke das ist gewissermaßen
die fortsetzung der runde mit anderen
mitteln es geht natürlich auch im tag um
die parteien in berlin auf dem weg in
eine neue koalition bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]